it is undeniably beautiful under its
stunning landscape Greenland is also
rich in mineral wealth and it's a lot
closer to America than Denmark but the
idea of the u.s. buying the territory
has it been a live one since President
Truman was in the White House so why did
Donald Trump a week or so ago suddenly
say he had his eyes on the place it
sounded like a bit of a joke at first
with this picture of a Trump Tower
plunked on it's landscape tweeted by the
president saying I promise not to do
this to Greenland but the joke it seems
is now over Trump abruptly canceling his
state visit to Denmark it seems a fit of
pique over its leaders rejection of his
Greenland idea it was an absurd idea was
nasty I thought it was an inappropriate
statement all she had to do is say no we
wouldn't be interested but we can't
treat the United States of America the
way they treated us under President
Obama
Denmark's Prime Minister Massie
Frederiksen seemed taken aback by the
news as well she might be it is with
regret and surprise that I received the
news that President Trump has canceled
his state visit to Denmark on the 2nd
and 3rd September I had been looking
forward to the visit our preparations
were well underway on the streets of
Copenhagen Danes were less circumspect
in their reaction to Donald Trump's
decision I heard it was because he
couldn't buy Greenland so if he's that
stupid I think it's good that he's not
coming
bring them is for the greenn people
and nobody else yet again former US
diplomats are horrified by the
president's behavior the world has
typically had very very high
expectations for us and as we look at
this chapter in American history I think
the world's expectations of us have
become much much lower this is a
president who loves a distraction and
could do with one with stock markets
tumbling and he doesn't like rejection
or the kind of ridicule that followed
his talk of buying Greenland but is it
more to do with this man Trump raised
the Greenland idea out of the blue two
days after news Barack Obama is also
going to Denmark at the end of September
could the two be linked Trump staff
became aware that President Obama was
planning to visit Denmark on the 28th of
September and the contrast between the
reception that would be given to
President Crump on the 3rd of September
and the reception that would be given to
former President Obama on the 28th made
them worry about the possibility for a
major presidential temper tantrum the US
president heads now for the g7 summit in
France after this latest insult to a
close American ally others gathering
there may be wondering who's next
Dominik Waghorn Sky News